this video is brought to you by patreon
thank you for your incredible support
stardust crusaders is a totally
different experience than i was
expecting araki's all like i'm glad you
liked the last two arcs because here's
something completely different
and to be perfectly honest i found this
to be viciously interesting and to my
surprise
inspirational for a manga cut to not
only throughout the magic system he
spent seven
large volumes establishing but to also
completely change the format with which
he structures his stories is not only
whiplash inducingly unconventional but
as i've learned by talking to friends
about part 3
is also pretty controversial this is a
polarizing arc to say the least and one
that i'm grateful has given me an
opportunity to explore from a narrative
point of view
why that might be but most importantly i
can't wait to give you all my opinion on
what is the first jojo part i'm going
into
largely blind this was the point where i
stopped watching the anime
and let me tell you i did not stop
reading the manga
in fact this was the arc that convinced
me that a rocky is not only
exceptionally brave
but incredibly clever also perhaps even
in ways you might not have ever noticed
so get your stand ready put on your best
hat hair and let's go on a long
sprawling adventure because i'm totally
not mark and this
is my review of the arc that changed
everything we knew about jojo's bizarre
adventure this is the controversial
the stylish and the inspirational
stardust crusades
[Music]
okay so phantom blood was 44 chapters
long battle tendency was 69.
nice but stardust crusaders well it's a
bit longer and by a bit longer i mean
it's 152
chapters this is a story that is more
than twice as long as battle tendency
and more than three times the length of
phantom blood
it's long and that's not a bad thing
however what it does mean is that it's
going to be too long to cover in just
one video and so this week i'll be
reviewing the first half and next week
i'll tackle the rest and
because i'm a professional in
preparation for this video i marinated
myself in every piece of pop culture
that defined the year that this arc was
released
1989 which included but was not limited
to
the first season of the simpsons lethal
weapon 2 and who could forget the iconic
and most aggressively 1989 experience to
be released perhaps
ever i am of course speaking of the
pinnacle of entertainment and generation
defining television program
saved by the bell praise be unto zach
morris this research proved to be
invaluable stardust crusaders released
in 1989 but set in 1987 japan follows
the adventures of one kujo joturo as he
learns of his new abilities thanks to
the help of his grandpa and friend ado
soon after this it's revealed that dio
has returned and with this certain
powers have surfaced within the joestar
family with jodorow and his grandpa
being strong enough to control them
jodaro's mother holly is not
and is on the verge of death thus is the
motivation for jotaro and his merry band
of friends to travel across the world to
stop dio in egypt making this story
particularly in the first half a long
road trip type story spanning many
different locations
perfectly mirroring november 18th 1989
saved by the bell episode wherein zack
wants to go on a field trip
only for it to get cancelled later and
funnily enough while status crusader's
story is long
it's not necessarily because there's a
lot of story in fact it's remarkably
barren in that department
and boy do i have a lot to discuss about
the characters the plot and the
structure of this particular section
i've done a lot of research for this arc
which turned out to be honestly unlike
anything i've come across before
so let's start at the beginning where i
think this story's greatest strengths
lie
before we dive into its controversial
material later
the setup in the beginning of this video
i mentioned that i hadn't seen the vast
majority of stardust crusaders and
that's true
but i did see the beginning of the arc
and if there's one thing that iraqi does
narratively really well it's
introducing new characters particularly
his main protagonist in a similar
fashion to jonathan and joseph within
phantom blood and battle tendency he
manages to in one scene
introduce us endear us to and get us
familiar with the protagonist of this
particular section
cujo jyotoro a 195 centimeter tall stoic
tough guy that is far more reserved than
any other jojo that's come before him
immediately this stands in direct
contrast to joseph joestar who is also
in this arc completely distinct to any
other jojo that came before him jotaro
boasts a much deeper and more reserved
demeanor at almost
all times pictured as a young boy in the
opening pages as we turn to the second
we are greeted by our new protagonist
now in a jail cell apart from the
situation being immediately interesting
the way a rocky uses the scene to build
up to the rest of the story
is honestly brilliant abrasive and
unkind from the outset this jotaro
character is clearly nothing like
anything we've seen before in the series
sporting honestly my favorite designer
of any jojo i've seen so far
although from my own observations online
this jojo is not without his detractors
but for me on this outing i grew to
appreciate his unique brand of
engagement with the story and even grew
to love it in some parts his no-nonsense
straightforward and abrasive persona
really makes
certain lines of dialogue hit
wonderfully well for instance in the
opening chapters jojo is in this jail
cell not because the police want him
there
in fact it's the opposite he is in there
because he believes that he's haunted by
a spirit that can hurt
people and not wanting to hurt anyone he
places himself there by his own volition
and while he's unkind and disconnected
from any meaningful relationship he
supposedly has in the outside world
including his own mother introduced also
to us within this scene are two very
important characters both in this tale
and jodaro's life the returning joseph
joestar and jodaro's mother
holly i found it to be honestly
refreshing to see a familiar face i was
so fond of in the prior arc surface and
play a large role
in this one too albeit he most
definitely doesn't have the same sway
over the series like he used to
partially because of the change in the
magic system but i'll get to that in a
moment
once again this scene does a fantastic
job in establishing jodaro's mother and
re-establishing joseph joestar as they
try to engage with and coax out of
hiding the increasingly adamant jotaro
before he eventually battles with
magicians red the power of one muhammad
abdul and friend of joseph
joestar
now something that might come as a
surprise to anyone that hasn't watched
or read this section of the manga is
that
the bulk of the story i'll be discussing
today actually takes place in the first
12 chapters or so and then
something happens that i will absolutely
be talking about in a moment
simply because that aspect of the story
is seen quite negatively
among the fandom and i've actually got
something i think i can add to the
conversation but to cut a long story
short dio is back a new power system
comes to the forefront of this arc and
because this new power requires a strong
will to wield when jodorow's mother
holly gains the new ability thanks to
her joestar bloodline lineage and can't
control it
jodaro immediately jumps into action and
seeks out dio to free his mother from
this curse and while on the surface that
action doesn't sound like much or
anything that would be noteworthy coming
from jodaro it absolutely is
from his time spent in jail to protect
others from himself to his time spent at
school defending others from a possessed
cacuein that joins the party later
jodaro exudes all the emotion of a plank
of wood and
in my first experience with the anime
this element bothered me to a point of
despising him
however this time around with the manga
i felt that because of that stoicism the
brief moments where the cracks start to
show in his persona
actually make a big impression on the
reader with my personal favorite example
of this being observed in the
relationship he has with his own mother
a number of times during the first 10
chapters he openly and loudly dismisses
his mother like the stereotypical
delinquent he's portrayed to be
however when he notices that she looks
pale and when she doesn't show up to
kiss him
he wonders where she's gone to while
these examples are in the anime there
are others that aren't quite as overt
these are small moments in isolation but
they paint a bigger picture of a
character who is virtuous and kind
behind that masquerade and it is by far
my favorite aspect
of his character however for most people
their favorite aspect of the story is
not jotaro
while many might love him or think he's
awesome because okay he is i'd be
willing to wager that this arc is as
iconic as it is because of one specific
element
i've neglected to talk about thus far
stance
this is largely why this is my favorite
setup out of all the jojo arcs thus far
and
not only does this act as our
inauguration to the character of jodaro
but also facilitates introductions to
much of the cast establishes
relationships and impresses upon us one
very new addition to the series
the iconic jojo's bizarre adventure
stand
magic system stands as a system of power
and battle are much more easily
diversifiable than hammond was
and thanks to iraqis wonderful
implementation of them they have become
synonymous with jojo's bizarre adventure
at this point acting effectively as
manifestations of one's own personal
willpower they come in all different
shapes and sizes and everyone gets their
own unique stand
jodoro stan comes to be known as star
platinum and while he's the most simple
of all the stands we see in this series
in that he is super fast and punches
really hard his appearances are made to
look all the more impressive because his
intense
and fast movements stand in direct
contrast with jonaro's reserved and
stoic persona once again jodaro's
personality serves to enhance more
elements of this story
um
[Music]
and this story is full of stance hamon
is old news and stans are here to stay
once the goal of traveling to egypt to
do battle with dio and to stop his evil
ways comes to the forefront of our
heroes minds
pretty much every other character we
meet along the way has a stand
and you best believe they more often
than not are sent by dio to stop the
team of jotaro joseph kakyoin abdul and
panorah from reaching
egypt this is a story three generations
in the making dio now wielding the body
of joseph's grandfather
jonathan after he sacrificed himself for
the betterment of his family and mankind
is now the body puppet of dio who is in
the manga depicted in shadow from
multiple volumes before he's eventually
revealed properly it's a great premise
for a story and one i am totally
on board with now some of you out there
who might be new to this series might be
asking
okay stands are cool and all but what
about hammond why do i see a distinct
lack of hammond and
since zack morris can freeze time does
he have a stand too all perfectly valid
questions
and while i can speak with absolute
certainty regarding sac morris's
standing in the jojo continuity when it
comes to the disappearance of hammond i
think it's an understandable question
for fans of the series to ask
what gives where's my hammond because
joseph and jonathan spent
massive sections of their respective
stories learning these fundamental
elements of the system
in order to compete against the evil
that they came up against and
in stardust crusaders hamon is barely
ever mentioned i can see why this might
have robbed fans of ham on the wrong way
however now after reading up to this
point in the series and after reading
araki's book
i think that's with good reason you see
jojo's bizarre adventure is structured
somewhat
unconventionally compared with other
long-running shonen
in that its main character consistently
changes from story act to story arc
this does wonders for the series in
keeping it feeling distinct from other
popular series within the issue of
weekly shonen jump
but it regrettably has i believe an
irritating side effect
specifically when it came to
implementing the hammond power system
there are obvious benefits in switching
from hamon to stand
powers when araki as a writer adopted
stans they granted him the flexibility
to give any person any ability
which automatically injects tons of
opportunity for creative storytelling
however i don't believe this to be the
only positive that influenced that
decision to shift gears entirely
i mean let's not forget jojo switching
from hammond to stands would be like if
dragon ball switched from key to pokemon
battles
vegeta look a pokemon
i'm not a pokemon i'm shout soon so
why the need to change things so
completely and fundamentally
and why stop using hammond altogether
well as i said
jojo's bizarre adventure structure was
unlike many long running shonen at the
time
teaching him on to jonathan was great as
it gave us the audience a chance to
better understand the power system and
it was great getting to see that
progression for the main character
however when it came time for joseph to
become the protagonist
araki was then faced with an interesting
problem how does he write joseph jose to
learn hamon without
it being boring and the conclusion he
came to was that he never taught joseph
hamon he just knew it by instinct
and this was by design and interestingly
araki draws attention to this aspect of
storytelling in his book manga in theory
and practice he talks about avoiding the
temptation to go negative with your
characters and to always be progressing
in an ever rising direction
under the rule of rises and falls you
are allowed to start in a negative place
and have the movement rise from there
when it comes to that ever-rising
direction
you can't make any compromises
interestingly hammond presented araki
with a very unique problem
how can he have a series where every
single time he starts a new arc he has
to teach the protagonist how to use the
hammond power
over and over without resetting to a
point with each arc
the answer he couldn't joseph started
from a place far more advanced than
jonathan did
and really that was the last time he
could in theory up the ante on that and
the solution he came up with to remedy
this dilemma was stan's
with stans he can introduce new
characters easily and keep things
interesting without retreading old
ground because
the stan can be as wacky and different
as he needs it to be from a writing
standpoint
this while initially jarring to fans of
hamon the hamon power system
simply couldn't work long term with its
structure and thus an
elegant solution was implemented with
stance personally i really enjoyed the
implementation of stands in the story
they add an immense amount of variety to
it
and on top of that lend opportunities
for a mangaka like araki
to get as creative as possible i mean
this one was a boat and its wielder was
an orangutan
[Music]
don't do that again okay all right so
there's no avoiding the topic that
status crusaders
is really long on top of the fact that
they already fundamentally changed the
formula of jojo's bizarre adventure
last week i released a poll on my
twitter asking jojo fans in my audience
if they liked stardust crusaders the
results while not being overwhelmingly
negative did have a sizable portion
of over one in five specifically stating
that they did not like it however what
was most interesting were the comments
within the comments section
comment after comment filled that
section citing that the ark dragged on
too long and that they didn't like the
episodic standalone nature of its
telling
leading for it to feel to some people
overly boring at times
yet strangely this is the arc that
supposedly launched jojo's bizarre
adventure into the mainstream this is
the one people point to as the part when
the series really starts to get good
in other words a vocal minority disliked
it somewhat or hated the arc while
others
loved it and that dichotomy and opinion
honestly fascinated me
so much so it led me down a rabbit hole
the likes of which brought to my
attention
a newfound respect for araki as a writer
[Music]
role
he mentions that around the time battle
tenancy was reaching its conclusion
the series was struggling in reader
surveys
now okay i can already see a few of you
glazing over from here
so you might be wondering what are these
reader surveys well
in the case of judge's bizarre adventure
because it was released in weekly shonen
jump when araki submitted new chapters
of jojo's bizarre adventure to be
published it did so alongside numerous
other mangakas submitting their latest
chapters
these weekly shonen jump issues were
filled with tons of different
popular stories that needed to stand out
and none were more popular than akira
toriyama's dragon ball at the time
however because they were filled with so
many different stories they couldn't
rely on weekly shonen jump sales figures
and so instead
supplied readers surveys at the end of
each issue asking them what their
favorite running stories were
series that did not perform well in
these surveys consistently
ran the risk of being cut from the
publication and the more i read about
this
it became increasingly more interesting
to me that araki decided to go against
every suggestion he received from the
higher ups and crafted a story like
stardust crusaders which is as i
mentioned above
unlike anything else that came before it
in the series
but not just because of stands because
of how it was structured too
what's with stardust crusader's bizarre
episodic pacing
once the goal is established and the
motivation is made clear in venturing to
egypt to stop dio and to save jodaro's
mother holly the story suddenly changes
the format it's implemented since the
very beginning
of the series changing from a serialized
story to an episodic or
monster of the week format for those of
you that don't know serialized stories
are narratives like dragon ball one
piece or attack and titan where there's
a clear progression and each chapter
informs and furthers the story in
obvious ways that typically don't repeat
episodic storytelling on the other hand
is closer to shows like
power rangers every week there's a new
monster to defeat and thus a passion
appears they fight as rangers before
eventually being overpowered and they
hop into their zords and boom
they win this is a formula that gets
reiterated time and time again until the
story is ready to proceed
and some people found that irritating
specifically nowadays
now if you recall at the beginning of
this video i put up a poll on my twitter
asking the fans of jojo if they liked
status crusaders now the vast majority
said yes
however what i haven't mentioned yet was
that i put up a second poll also
this one asked do you like stardust
crusaders
monster of the week format and the
results were
very different clearly i struck a nerf
in other words there's not much story
within this part of stardust crusaders
and this bothered a significant chunk of
the fan base
once the setup is established and the
characters go on their merry way
jotaro and the crew might as well be
walking through mount moon encountering
zubat after zubat because the number of
random encounters they get on their way
to egypt is
quite relentless additionally that's
also predominantly why in this video it
sounds like i've only just started
talking about the story because
in this section of it there's really
very little meat to discuss beyond the
different stand users they encounter
time and time again as they get closer
to their goal of egypt
and the reason behind this seemingly
sudden and insane narrative decision
to change the format of the story turned
out to be one of the single most
interesting discoveries i made regarding
jojo's bizarre adventure and
maybe even any review i've ever done in
response to poor reader surveys during
battle tendency araki's response
was stardust crusaders an episodic
non-narratively driven
road trip across the globe to egypt at
the time as i said within the
publication weekly shonen jump dragon
ball was extremely popular among readers
and at the time dragon ball had just
finished a series of tournament arcs and
as a result editors working for shonen
jump would suggest tournaments be
written into any of the stories that
were struggling and in his book araki
speaks on this
during the height of the popularity of
the tournament manga i was able to
approach them as a reader and enjoy the
excitement but i couldn't help but
wonder from a creator's point of view
what the mangaka would do after the top
of the tournaments
at the time jojo was struggling in the
reader surveys and people even suggested
that i add a tournament format to help
me gain popularity
despite this advice to go for the safe
easily understood serialized format of a
tournament which would have also given
him plenty of opportunity to demonstrate
the stand powers in a much more easy to
control environment he instead
effectively
does the opposite not only ignoring all
the advice he was given but
turns the series on its head effectively
changing a lot of what made jojo
well jojo for the existing reader base
and there are plenty of cons to this
typically speaking for a long-running
shonen serialization works much more
effectively at telling engaging
character-driven stories with each
chapter enjoying the opportunity for
cliffhangers to help sustain its reader
base
and at this point fans of the series
might actually start to notice that
during this section there aren't that
many cliffhangers and even if you look
at shows that use episodic format to
their benefit like early simpsons or
rick and morty these shows would turn
the absurdity up to 11 and
perform a host of different crazy
stories all the time to help keep an
audience engaged however with stardust
crusaders it very much follows the exact
same format over
and over again show up in an area the
team notices that something isn't quite
right
it's the work of an enemy stand user
they then fight that user and that user
eventually falls
and they repeat this ad nauseam with
slight variations here and there it
seems as though there's no benefit but
there actually
is with the format of episodic monster
of the week storytelling the story
suddenly becomes incredibly accessible
the way the format often works is that
it lends well to establishing existing
main characters for the sake of a new
viewer or reader time and time again
with each chapter which is largely why
the side characters in the story feel
more engaging they get much more screen
time and as a result the opportunity to
build themselves up and suddenly because
of this easy accessibility
status crusaders abruptly didn't need
its reader base to catch up with the
near 100 chapters of material that
already existed
shame and instead they could just hop on
this easy to understand journey at any
point and enjoy the standalone
encounters that popped up time and time
again
and in that time get to know all the
characters and eventually
the story in other words araki ignored
the advice of professionals that thought
they knew better
and instead risked everything he built
in a ridiculously competitive industry
on his own understanding of how story
works while also introducing and
establishing a brand new power system in
stands that he wasn't fully to grips
with yet
[Applause]
[Music]
that is one of the bravest things i've
ever heard a mangaka do
so often in pop culture and media do
visionaries take the safe route and copy
what's popular
i'm sure you've all noticed it when
everything game related wanted to mimic
fortnite's success in implementing a
battle royale feature
you saw when dc wanted to fast-track its
franchise into being an ensemble hero
team like the avengers and you saw it
when dragon ball success
informed the countless tournament arcs
of its time but what isn't spoken about
nearly enough are the visionaries the
true visionaries that when faced with
certain doom
grit their teeth dig their heels in and
declare that they understand
how their medium works and that they
genuinely believe in their own ideas
regardless if no one else does so and
from those truly brave writers and
illustrators you don't get stories that
try to copy something else to gain
popularity you instead get an iconic
franchise that spans
generations you don't need to be
inspired instead you're the one making
something that inspires
others and so while i haven't spoken too
much about the strange and bombastic
journey that jotaro and his friends
underwent on their way to egypt i really
don't think the important aspects of it
are the details of this particular
journey but the philosophy behind its
creation
stardust crusaders while i didn't love
its first half's format through my
research it has become a story that i
respect
more than possibly any other i've ever
read in my life
and it deserves to be known as the
iconic arc
it's become thanks for watching guys i
know i didn't cover a lot of the
meat and potatoes regarding the stand
battles this weeks particularly in this
section but i promise next week when i
cover the second half and climax of this
long journey i'll also go back over some
of these stand battles in more detail
and i'll tell you all my favorites
because if there's anything the ending
of stardust crusaders taught me it's
when i wake up in the morning and as
long as i don't want it i don't think
i'll ever make it on time
by the time i grab my books and i give
myself a look i'm at the corner just in
time
[Music]